[Musique]
j'ai envie de me faire plaisir du coup
j'ai envie de faire plaisir et ça c'est
la base pour que les gens ne ressentent
dans l'assiette c'est rarement
nous-mêmes se créer un peu d'émotion en
interne derrière les fourneaux pour
pouvoir donner après j'ai toujours voulu
être chef cuisinier j'ai toujours voulu
avoir mon restaurant c'est
voilà j'avais des rêves je pensais pas
qu'ils allaient se concrétiser aussi
rapidement on les fait cuire juste sur
la braise comme ça ça donne un bon petit
goût de fumée en fait homard on va tous
dans le même sens tout se passionné et
pour vraiment que les gens se faut
prendre vachement le plaisir
homard sur la braise des bouillons des
sauces dans la cuisine autour des
fourneaux la brigade jeune travaille aux
côtés du talentueux Clément Dumont 27
ans seulement
pas forcément pour la mise en place et
très important du coup on est sûr qu'il
y a jamais rien qui manque on n'est pas
forcément à l'aise avec tout au début
donc ça je pense que le chef l'a bien
compris et c'est ce qui nous permet de
travailler assez sereinement quand même
voilà enfin moi j'avoue que le matin je
vérifie je suis content quoi c'est une
cuisine un peu de condiments une cuisine
authentique et une cuisine qui utilise
beaucoup les produits de la région des
produits terroir et ça c'est très très
important les produits du terroir
justement Clément Dumont vient les
glaner à quelques mètres du restaurant
dans les rues de Loches
[Musique]
et c'est parti chez le maraîcher
bonjour
c'est une fraîcheur dans la chance c'est
pas une fois par semaine c'est deux fois
donc normalement on cherche pas les
chambres froides on fait vraiment que
sur la fraîcheur on revient voilà ça
fait deux jours et on revient on se
recharge et puis on repart
voilà bonne journée à vous on a bien
fait parce qu'on a eu un accueil des
Lochois qui a été extraordinaire des
commerçants des habitants enfin le choix
est Sud Touraine dans la globalité mais
mais voilà ils ont été d'une force avec
nous enfin voilà il nous c'est eux aussi
tous les jours qui nous pousse à aller
plus loin et ce qui nous soutiennent en
fait et ça et ça c'est
ça fait chaud au coeur Clément Dumont a
grandi à Chinon passer par des
établissements de renom à Courchevel
Saint-Barthélémy son expérience la plus
marquante avec Pascal Cayeux au Grand
Hôtel de Cala Rossa encore aujourd'hui
son travail de précision se focaliser
essentiellement sur condiment bouillon
et sauce
très attentif là dessus donc forcément
Arnaud dunkel voilà on a bien forcément
à lui parce que
je pense c'est le mettre en la matière
et j'ai eu la chance en plus d'y aller
il y a quelques semaines et
effectivement là j'ai pris une sacrée
claque au menu ce jour-là endives braisé
mayonnaise au safran mayonnaise à
l'étude de mer et sa truite cuite à
basse température sauce au cresson une
cuisinière Bassée végétale florale une
Aude assez racines tourangères tu sais
que tous les jours tu vis pour ça tous
les jours ça t'anime en fait on a besoin
de donner du plaisir